ready
action
cars continued to come up the steep
incline from marlborough street
augie noticed a car that neither turned
around nor continued on toward the
parking lot
[Music]
showing up to a job sir in the
mercedes-benz sign of the times i guess
right
it's unusually bright headlights cutting
through the fog
why is he just waiting there and the car
leaped forward
[Music]
then time ran out
you got 16 dead somebody lost control he
didn't lose control
it's always such a rush to see something
that you wrote
come to life it's a good
merging of the producer the director the
cast the crew
action
greetings detective you know who i am
and what i did
i believe i've been contacted by he's
the mercedes killer
there's nothing like being able to sit
down and immerse yourself
in an ongoing story this is him isn't it
i hope people will binge mr mercedes on
peacock
been hiding in plain sight right under
my nose
next i think that it would be a pretty
nice
halloween treat what do you think
explains a person like that
it's attractive to write about a villain
like brady who's out of his mind
i'm just
really wise pissing off a lunatic brady
taunts
bill hodges and becomes a duel of wits
between these two
where does this end when i get him
it's a fantastic show
you